yesterday the federal reserve decided to
raise interest rates by 75 basis points
this is the second consecutive time that
they've raised the interest rate by such
an aggressive measure if we go back to
november of last year we had inflation
teeing around seven percent and the
federal reserve started to talk
aggressively saying that they needed to
destroy demand and bring the market back
into a more rational zone a lot of folks
didn't believe them but the federal
reserve has now done multiple interest
rate hikes and they've started to
conduct quantitative tightening in order
to make financial conditions something
that will bring the high inflation down
now raising interest rates by 75 basis
points is not something that they were
anticipating at the end of q1 of this
year but now here we are and they've
done it two different times if we look
at the coverage we can see that folks
are openly discussing that the federal
reserve is raising interest rates by 75
basis points specifically to tamp down
runaway inflation without creating a
recession
jerome powell had some choice words he
said that as the stance of monetary
policy tightens further it will likely
become appropriate to slow the pace of
increases while we assess how our
cumulative policy adjustments are
affecting the economy and inflation of
course this brings up the topic of a
recession and according to the fomc they
say that recent indicators of spending
and production have softened nonetheless
job gains have been robust in recent
months and the unemployment rate has
remained low jerome powell also
confirming that he does not believe we
are in a recession he said think what a
recession is it's a broad-based decline
across many industries that sustained
more than a couple of months this
doesn't seem like that now the real
reason is the labor market has been such
a strong signal of economic strength
that it makes you question the gdp data
now that is absolutely incredible to see
the chairman of the federal reserve
openly stating that he is questioning
the gdp data what does he know that we
don't know we're supposed to look at the
gdp data and have confidence in it but
we have the leader of the central bank
saying that maybe we shouldn't take it
at face value
regardless of what they say just look at
the data
two consecutive negative growth quarters
of gdp we are in a recession the federal
reserve was conducting asset purchases
and holding interest rates artificially
low when inflation was over seven
percent they finally realized they had
to destroy demand and tried to address
the inflation
and now we are in a fed induced
recession they have been hiking interest
rates as we move into that recession
sure employment is strong right now and
consumer spending is still growing but
we're seeing early signs hiring freezes
layoffs and consumers starting to
psychologically realize the recession is
on the horizon
over the coming months my guess is that
this data is going to turn and we will
see more and more data points confirming
that we in fact are in a recession the
federal reserve is going to have to
pivot they cannot continue to take an
aggressive quantitative tightening
stance
we have to get relief to the market or
else we risk going into a severe
recession and potentially a depression
now i don't think that that's likely to
happen because i think the fed will
pivot i think we will return to loose
monetary policy that is the macro
structure in which the economy is built
to survive on ultimately you just simply
have to survive the coming months until
the fed waves that white flag
loose monetary policy will make a return
in some cases it may come back with a
vengeance
until then the fed's in control it's all
one big trade and right now the u.s
economy is in a recession and until the
fed pivots we're not coming out of it